and as Jane was saying what's
particularly usual about this not only
is the human tragedy of students who are
sitting their exams and doing first-aid
training who've been gunned down it's
also the fact that this continues to be
an ongoing situation and the number of
pupils involved is simply so large 500
were told 500 pupils in the school along
with teachers and teaching staff at the
time of this Taliban attack the
Pakistani army are trying to end this
siege journalists at scene say they've
heard very heavy gunfire from inside the
school as the soldiers surrounded
helicopters have also been heard
overhead some reports that the soldiers
have now got into the school that are
going from classroom to classroom to try
to clear the militants out let's bring
you the latest with neva Lazarus who's
in Delhi for us Neville the numbers have
climbed significantly in the last few
minutes haven't they were reporting 21
just a matter of 10 minutes ago now up
to 84 what's the latest you're hearing
from the Chief Minister of the province
of KP saying that 84 children have been
killed and as many numbers have been
injured some critically we don't really
know exactly how many how many what's
the final figure yet as you mentioned
the army army personnel are going going
through the premises and checking
checking the place to see what what what
what kind of what kind of deaths are
still still around there but at the
moment he also confirmed that only three
militants were killed now we know from
from from the earlier reports that about
six of them were in the school they have
dressed up in an army uniform fired the
way inside inside the premises and
scattered around one militant seems to
have is reported to have detonated a
device on him himself killing him
killing himself but we don't have a
clear idea if there are still any more
militants there at the moment